the pm attentive on a visit to a school
in south london but the words he's
really waiting on are those written in
sue gray's report after months of
waiting her investigation into illegal
gatherings in downing street and
whitehall due this week with great
respect not going to
comment or give any running commentary
on
her report until we get it and i i think
that
to be frank the moment is not very far
off um it can't be long now before i'll
be able to say something but i really
want to wait as i've said for a long
time now until suitable no running
commentary but tonight fresh pictures
emergent of the prime minister drinking
in downing streets at an apparent
leaving do in november 2020 when the
country was told to stay at home except
for limited reasons and all the while
the pm insisted no guidance was broken
will the prime minister tell the house
whether there was a party in downing
street on the 13th of november
prime minister
mr speaker no but i'm sure that whatever
happened the guidance was followed and
the rules were followed at all times not
the police's verdict fines were issued
for this event although the prime
minister escaped penalty the lib dems
tonight right into the independent
office for police conduct asking them to
explain why that was saying it's
undesirable for the public to be left in
the dark labour also demanding
explanations i think people are going to
ask questions and that's for the police
to answer but are you going to ask
questions well i think the police have
to answer those questions quite clearly
on why they didn't think that was
breaking the rules but i know for
certain that boris johnson knows that
he's had dozens of parties now in number
10. it's pretty clear that he was
toasting the at these events when he
said he didn't know that any parties
occurred
when the sue grey report comes out it
will be ugly from civil servants
behaving to quote one figure in an
indefensible manner to the failure of
leadership from boris johnson and his
senior team but the prime minister's
trump card is that the met despite all
the uncomfortable photos and evidence
haven't issued him with multiple fines
and while the pressure of course will
build around the publication of the grey
report the acid test is will boris
johnson's mp's attempt to unseat him and
for now they seem to have other matters
on their minds
for those in marginal seats in the north
of england success at the next general
election won't be determined by events
that took place two years ago but
instead by the action the government
takes now my constituents aren't talking
about
partygate particularly in the north in
what we call the red wall they're
talking about the challenges for the
cost of living they want the government
to really focus on issues that matter to
them
in the coming days at least the focus
will be back on this place and the
culture behind this door beyond that and
after the cobwebs of partygate lyft it's
the public who will need to decide beth
rigby sky news westminster